well let's say very good morning to
Douglas Alexander mr. Alexander want to
talk mainly about Syria but all to start
first of all with Afghanistan and no
doubt you want to pay tribute to and the
labors candidate in the European
elections who was killed in that awful
bomb attack in Kabul on Friday yes it
was a callous and currently murder he
was a liberal candidate but he was also
an aid worker and a campaigner for
justice and it speaks to the fact that
that kind of terrible terrible attack is
just a politics of Miller's and it
offers nothing to the international
community but most importantly it offers
nothing to the international community
or to the people of Afghanistan he was
there trying to help the people of
Afghanistan and that's why even in the
remaining months when there are
international combat forces in the
country it is important that the work
continues to build up the Afghan
security forces so that they can step up
as the international forces step back
but Tommy's running out I mean after a
13-year mission we're now down to the
last few months in the capital itself
that's made me running the country is
demonstrably not safe well the Taliban
have been attempting for many years what
and the terrible poor laws of war is
called spectaculars in Kabul they've
been unsuccessful many more times than
they've been successful in bringing that
terror to the capital but you're right
to recognize it's still an environment
that is very challenged in terms of
security and that's why there's a very
important burden of responsibility on
the Afghan security forces ok well let's
turn to Syria now we've got some peace
talks with some of the opposition there
the Assad regime there are obviously
some notable exceptions there what are
your hopes for I mean expectations must
be well dampened down right on honestly
my hopes are limited but given the scale
of the slaughter that we are still
witnessing in Syria it is vital that
these talks take place I welcome the
fact that the Syrian National Council
agreed yesterday in Turkey to come to
the talks on Wednesday in Switzerland
but if you talk about what can actually
be achieved given that we are dealing
with both a regime and with rebel forces
still engaged in heavy combat in Syria I
think we've got to be realistic as to
what we should aim for certainly I would
hope that a process would be put in
place this week that could be carried
forward there are individual
confidence building measures that I
think should be worked towards whether
that is corridors of humanitarian access
so that people can actually reach the
many millions of people in suffering
within Syria in addition to that
localized ceasefires in addition to that
making sure perhaps that we could see
prisoner exchanges which is one of the
other measures that have been talked
about so I think there are some
achievable confidence-building measures
that could be aimed at this week at the
same time as working towards a longer
term engagement between all of the sites
I've argued for many months it may be a
baby steps and you managing some small
yes but also I think we need some
structural genes I've argued for Iran to
be part of a contact group bringing
together if you like the principal
sponsors to the conflict and given how
difficult it is to find a way for so
what not out these talks but sitting in
an arterial or so and I place the
Foreign Secretary on Monday in the house
of commons on exactly this issue I think
it'll be a matter of regret if Iran is
not at these talks because on any
reckoning given its heavy responsibility
supporting Assad providing troops
providing weapons it's a key actor on
the Syrian stage and as we've seen with
the chemical weapons deal once you get
those previous adversary's in this case
Russia and other countries together you
actually can make some progress so I
think it will be a matter of regret if
Iran is not there but it's still
important to try and make progress on
you asked about the humanitarian side of
thing do you think Britain could play a
bigger role for instance in accepting
refugees we all know about the huge
strain that those refugees are putting
on neighboring countries Jordan Turkey
and all other kinds of countries what
about Britain should think better share
i think there's three approaches that
need to be taken first of all and I
think Britain is getting this right
there is significant support going into
humanitarian work both on the edges of
the country and in the neighboring
countries secondly I think we should do
more to support those neighboring
countries to look at the number of
refugees that are no resident within
turkey with in Lebanon within Jordan I
think the British government should look
at what further regional support can be
given and yes I do think consideration
should be given to the whole
international community recognizing its
responsibilities in relation to refugees
for example those were very severe
medical conditions who perhaps are not
able to receive the kind of treatment
that they need whether in camps in
Jordan and Turkey kind of turn to
President Assad okay the regime at the
talks it's about regime change
that's the only condition that the
opposition of guns Rio to those talks
about is about changing the regime well
it's not what a sad sad just come up on
the Reuters news why it's not ready to
give up power issue is not up for
discussion at these talks I mean that's
the point is well that's not all that's
not altogether surprising that i'm not
so not surprising but not before go
either can you but you have you faced a
pretty brutal choice is it better
further to be talks albeit with genuine
and continuing disagreements between the
parties even about what the talks are
aiming for or to have no talks at all
and i given the fact that we're now
looking at more than two million people
displaced within the country six
millions to me into place across the
region six moving de placed within the
country more than 125,000 people having
died in the last two or three years i
think it is better to have
representatives of assad in the room
talking the not to be present albeit
that the opposition have only turned up
on the basis that there would be a
transitional government formed by
consent and you're absolutely right the
opposition parties will make clear that
for them to consent to transitional
government will require the absence not
the presence of a site and i start
saying well it's not even going to be on
the table there the Assad regime saying
as they have always said since 2011 we
are fighting international terrorism it
may not have been the case in 2011 it's
looking a bit more like that now doesn't
he have a point well it's certainly the
case that there are jihad ease and
international fighters know within Syria
but that I think strengthens the
argument for finding the only long-term
solution which is an inclusive political
settlement the only basis to get that
inclusive political settlement is to
have talks often with parties disagree
profoundly indeed you are trying to kill
each other within Syria which is why
what happens on Wednesday I hope is the
start of another chapter in the Syrian
story but how can sound are you about
radicalization taking place in Syria
we've heard back German concerns French
concerns we know about our own security
services all the work they're doing
there is real radicalization one of the
questions I asked the Foreign Secretary
was could he give me the assurance but I
was looking for that the British
intelligence agencies are doing
everything they can to monitor for
example the number of British citizens
who have gone in as foreign fighters
into Syria but the truth is this is no
longer simply a Syrian issue
we have a crescent of crisis that
stretches from Iraq you saw the
difficulties in terms of al-qaeda and
Fallujah you see what is happening in
Syria you see the attempts that are
being made for a cue to get a foothold
within Lebanon and actually this does
demand that coordinated regional
response of which I've spent any
pesticide have a point he's doing all he
can to fight al-qaeda listen Assad beers
very heavy responsibility for the murder
and the slaughter that were witnessing
within Syria and I think before he
starts trying to persuade the
international community of other
people's voices there needs to be a
degree of humility as to his own
responsibility what started as a
democratic process he's turned into not
just a civil war but what we risk now is
a real regional war by proxy okay well
thank you for now to your role as a
general election coordinator fellow but
we've had your leader on the Andrew Marr
show just a few minutes ago and it seems
now after much criticism of Labor of not
getting any policies out of you will get
some very detailed step-by-step
practical and credible solutions to what
you define is the cost of living crisis
so we're going to see more of that
that's as welcome as a question as it's
unexpected yes but we got to see more of
that I mean this is a barrage with us
human than election more than a year as
I moved through the Parliament of course
we're going to be setting out specific
practical policies we think should be
taken that address both the immediate
concerns of living standards in the
country but also looks at the longer
showing changes that are needed so we
can earn our away this might not be what
I reading because you know the
opposition saying you the government's
handing it severed is saying well this
is about quick fixes you got no
long-term black well if you look for
example at the changes that Ed Miliband
seto on Freddie in terms of the banks
the fact that we've got a serious
problem with retail banking in this
country the fact that all too often the
small businesses of this country seem to
be serving the banks rather than the
bank's supporting and serving the small
businesses that's pretty profound change
and in that sense whether it is
long-term change in relation to banking
whether it is long-term change in terms
of small businesses those are exactly
the steps will be setting out as well as
the immediate responses like resetting
the energy market but putting in place a
price freeze well those changes of
people but if you look at the team that
Mr Miliband is going to lead into battle
do you have a gap right at the core of
economic policy i'm talking about the
shadow chancellor here
he's lost his mojo he predicted a
triple-dip recession it didn't happen is
Ed Balls really not kind of punching
above his weight hey listen I think
there's no doubt not least on the basis
of what ed miliband said this morning on
the Andrew Marr program that Ed is going
to be an absolutely key central and I
think very positive figure in terms of
taking that case to the conservatives
about why they're flatlined the economy
for three years but also setting out the
kind of structural changes we need to
the economy so that we can grow an
errand are we to higher living standards
in the future hmm but he's lost his mojo
is what's Eddie and he predicted that
triple dip recession there wasn't even a
double so there's a double-dip he was no
forgive me stories come and go in the
newspapers I think what's important is
having a plan for the kind of economy
that we want having the intellectual
rigor and policy strength to actually be
able to devise the solutions for the
challenges the country faces and in that
sense I think we've got a team that can
take us to bj's know you to download zi2
I isn't it yeah you had a stand-up rowdy
for the very least about Europe listen
I've worked with it for 20 years in fact
of what with both heads for 20 years in
that sense one of the resolutions we
meet when we moved into a position in
2010 because we had front row seats at
the TB jeebies was we were never going
to allow any differences any personality
issues to get in the way of our shared
responsibility must speak as you see I
mean you know any you know each other so
well you've grown up politically today I
think it's I think it's a good thing
that as a team you can debate discuss
and then decide and move forward that's
what we've done that's why I think
actually we haven't done what previous
generations of liberal politicians have
done when they went into a position
which is to form a circular filing
scored and about a decade get their act
together the fact that we are ahead in
the opinion polls the fact we are making
plans for the kind of country that we
think labour could deliver after 2015 i
think is testimony to the extent to
which we've shown we will work together
in the national interest okay but have
you sorted out me we hear that the Rye
between you and airballs was about your
a policy we very clear about how labour
will go into the general election on
Europe will you be offering some kind of
referendum or only a referendum if there
is substantial treaty firstly on Europe
we believe the right Road for Britain is
reformed in Europe nor exit from Europe
if you had as many cabinet members in
need of as many different answers from
the Tories on that side
in relation to the referendum we believe
the only basis on which a decision like
that can be made is not actually the
internal divisions like in the Tory
party but in the national interest and
we judge the national interest is this
we don't think committing no to an inert
referendum in the future is the right
choice for the country that was our
position last week it was our position
last year the party that seems a staff
position the party that seems to be
shifting a vote I'm afraid is the
conservative okay last thought on these
televised Li but leaders debate took
place in 2010 labour bang up for it so
to speak in the jug absolutely between
christmas and new year i made clear in
an interview that we wanted to start the
negotiations in this year with what
we've called the 333 formula that is
three leaders with three debates over
three weeks since then i welcome the
fact that nick clegg the Liberal
Democrat leader has embraced the
proposition I put on the table but the
risks being an empty seat at those
negotiations and that's the seat that
should be filled by David Cameron so I'm
very happy to reiterate my challenge
today to David Cameron don't run don't
hide bring yourself to the table let's
start the basis of negotiations with the
successful formula from 2010 the British
people I think deserve to have the
people who are offering themselves as
Prime Minister willing to put themselves
forward for a job interview at the time
of the election okay shadow foreign
secretary thank you very much indeed
Douglas Alexander